senators Mike Lee and Joni Ernst have
unveiled a new conservative welfare
program to address the problem of low
birth rates paid parental leave we will
examine how the road to hell is paved
with good intentions
then Alexandria Ocasio cortes
embarrasses herself I know you're
shocked this time in front of Wells
Fargo CEO Tim Sloan and the co-founder
of Greenpeace warns that the green New
Deal will destroy civilization I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
some of the greatest video in modern
political history thanks to Alexandria
Casio Cortez and Wells Fargo CEO Tim
Sloan but first we have got to thank
micro and micro works oh my goodness if
you are looking for more great podcasts
to listen to but you are short on time
you have got to check out the way I
heard it with Mike Rowe this podcast
gives a really unique take on American
history explore everything from pop
culture to politics actors to athletes
history to Hollywood and each episode is
10 minutes or less this really reminds
me just the micros whole character I
mean micros whole approach to this and
the format of the podcast itself it
really reminds me of Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan's old radio show it is so
good you can't turn it off the micro
presents stories for the curious mind
with a short attention span isn't that
all of us his storytelling is
reminiscent of the late Paul Harvey's
the rest of the story and it's it's just
really clever it's the number one short
form podcast in America it's been
downloaded more than 87 million times
start off with episode 36 which is
called oh brother I listen I'm a history
buff so I actually know I know a lot of
the background to these stories and this
one even had me guessing I thought gosh
what is it you don't quite know what the
ending is until you get there you don't
quite know exactly who you're talking
about it's about a sibling rivalry
between a man and his golden child
brother in this case it's one of most
shocking and notorious moments in
presidential history go to micro comm
slash podcast today to listen and
subscribe to the way I heard it mi ke ro
w e comm slash podcast micro comm slash
podcast I really want to talk about the
paid parental leave proposal the
nominally conservative paid parental
leave proposal that's coming out from
Mike Lee and Joni Ernst because I think
a lot of conservatives are getting this
wrong I think it's coming from a place
of good intentions I think it's
addressing a real problem but this bill
just doesn't get it right but but before
we do that I just have to show you one
of the most glorious bits of tape that I
have this was Alexandria Ocasio cortez
grilling
and questioning the CEO of Wells Fargo
Tim Sloan there listen she's had a lot
of moments in her brief political career
where she has demonstrated her ignorance
and her arrogance none even comes close
to this exchange here's how she begins
um mr. Sloane why was the bank involved
in the caging of children and financing
the caging of children to begin with I
don't know how do they answer that
question because we weren't so in
finance you you were financing involved
in debt financing of course if ik and
geo group correct for a period of time
we were involved in financing one of the
firms were not anymore and the other I'm
not familiar with the specific assertion
that you're making but we weren't
directly involved in that okay so these
companies run private detention
facilities run by ice which which is
involved in in caging children but I'll
move on this reminded me and her
reaction to it reminded me if you've
ever seen on Always Sunny the episode
where Charlie pretends to be a lawyer
that's what it's like watching
Alexandria Cassio Cortez actually be a
congressman I know a lot about the lawn
various other lowerings I'm
well-educated well-versed I know that
situations like this real estate wise
they're very complex actually they're
pretty simple the forms are all standard
boilerplate okay well we're all hungry
we're gonna get to our hot plates soon
enough all right but let's talk about
the contract you sorry
I forgot where did you go to law school
again well I could ask you that very say
I went to Harvard mm-hmm how about you
where yeah I'm pleading the fifth sir
I'd advise that you dude don't take that
advice into cooperation all right now
let's say you and I go toe-to-toe on
bird law and see who comes out to
victory you know I don't think I'm gonna
do anything close to that and I can see
clearly you know nothing about the law
it seems like you have a tenuous grasp
on the English language in general
yeah well filibuster you do you do you
know what that word means
yeah what's that mean that's a I see
breaking her way out of the door out of
the wall to the capital yeah well so
what were you doing there with the
caging of children may might I ask we
didn't do that okay Touche mr. CEO but
if you were caging I mean there is very
little difference between the two she
goes on you would think that this
Congress or machine oh she has a lot of
attention on her you would think that
she might do even a moment's research to
see which projects the bank had brokered
which which projects the bank had been
involved in no no no he or she goes on
the Keystone XL pipeline mr. Sloan Wells
Fargo was also an investor in a major
investor in the Dakota access pipeline
the Keystone XL pipeline's they were
prime investors and lenders to companies
building these pipelines in defiance of
Standing Rock Sue's treaty rights to
protect its water and sacred lands they
warned early on the Lakota Sioux warned
early on that the pipeline was unstable
and bound to leak despite that it was
built anyway and it has leaked at least
five times and the Keystone XL in
particular had one leak that leaked
210,000 gallons across South Dakota
since Wells Fargo financed the building
of this pipeline in an and in in an
environmentally unstable way why
shouldn't the bank be held responsible
for financing the cleanup of the
disasters from these projects which
pipeline are you referring to um either
you know so we were not involved in the
financing of the exit of the XL pipeline
we were one of the 17 or 19 banks that
was involved in the financing of the
Dakota access pipeline okay so so Wells
Fargo hasn't financed any company
associated with the Keystone XL
no I didn't say that I said we're not
involved in financing that pipeline
specifically okay so let's focus on the
Dakota access pipeline okay okay well
okay well so I guess someone should have
told me about that but okay so the point
that she's actually trying to make a
point that also doesn't make any sense
but just on this basic level this is
what's worrisome I find about the aoc
era of politics which is that facts
don't matter she said this sometimes
people are concerned about being
factually correct instead of morally
right you can't be morally right without
being factually correct and she didn't
do five seconds research and you would
think okay if this woman isn't exactly
the brightest bulb in the pack maybe she
should hire people who are smart and
then they can do the research for her
she's done this on her Twitter account
to some success but they didn't do their
very basic research here and so this guy
makes her look like a total fool so then
she has to pivot Jesus okay well I just
just talking about the Keystone XL which
Wells Fargo was not involved in
whatsoever
now let me pivot and make my stupid
point with regard to the Dakota access
pipeline as did Wells Fargo be held
responsible for the damages incurred by
climate change due to the financing of
fossil fuels and and these projects I
don't know how you'd calculate that
congressman I'm safe from spills or when
we have to reinvest in infrastructure
building sea walls from the erosion of
from the erosion of infrastructure or
cleanups wildfires etc related to that
pipeline I'm not aware that there's been
any of what you described that's
occurred about the cleanups from the
leaks of the Dakota access pipeline I'm
not aware of the do leaks associated
with the Dakota access pipeline that
you're describing so hypothetically if
there wasn't leak Dakota access pipeline
well but what shouldn't you have to pay
for Armageddon when our mageddon happens
ma'am I'm not aware that Armageddon has
happened yeah okay well but shouldn't
but hypothetically and the
hypothetically is so devastating because
first
why is she asking this banker a
hypothetical question what does that
have to do with anything but it's it's
the logical consequence of it doesn't
matter if you're factually right this is
actually where you end up if you say
doesn't matter if you're factually right
you just have to be morally right then
you get into hypothetical this is all
the time I mean you could apply this to
Jessie Smollett you could apply this to
the fake hate crime hoaxes you can apply
this to everything they'll say look at
this awful terrible thing you said that
didn't really happen say well maybe that
didn't happen but it gets to a greater
truth say no it gets to a lie it didn't
happen and so now it's a lie and you're
trying to have me defend a lie so now
she goes into this she gets into the
greater truth and she says
hypothetically Ornt you on the hook
hypothetically if there was a leak from
the Dakota access pipeline why should a
Wells Fargo pay for the cleanup of it if
since it paid for the construction of
the pipeline itself because we don't
operate the pipeline we provide
financing to the company that's
operating the pipeline our
responsibility is to ensure that at the
time that we make that loan that that
that customer and we have a group of
people in Wells Fargo including an
environmental oversight group headed by
one of my colleagues who used to be at
the EPA once I did Wells Fargo financed
this pipeline when it was widely seen to
be environmentally unstable again the
reason that we were one of the 17 or 19
banks that financed that is because our
team reviewed the environmental impact
and we concluded that it was it was a
risk that we were willing to take
absolutely devastating the question
she's asking is why is the bank not
liable if some accident happens with a
project that the bank finances and his
answer is because we're a bank
we didn't we're not building the
pipeline we're not operating the
pipeline she says yeah but but what's a
bank well miss ocasion Cortez a bank
provides liquidity to mark
we are extending financing to other
people who are engaging in other
products she-she a few weeks ago came
out and proved that she doesn't know
what a tax incentive is she thought at
what a tax incentive is is you say okay
you can come here you're gonna do
business you're gonna owe taxes to the
municipality or the state or the
government and in exchange for you
coming here to do that business and
create all of these jobs we're going to
lower your tax bill a little bit that's
what a tax incentive is it's not a pile
of slush money that's just sitting in a
drawer we'll say if you come here we'll
give you a bunch of money that's what
she thought attacks and sentiments now
we find out she doesn't know what a bank
does this woman is a legislator in our
federal government and what this reminds
me of is that moment I remember this a
number of years ago whenever it was a
Lloyd Blankfein they CEO of Goldman
Sachs was testifying I believe before
Congress and it was just a ton of idiots
asking him stupid questions and Lloyd
Blankfein who's smarter than all of them
combined just sitting there sort of
rubbing his head in annoyance this man I
mean this is the difference between the
public and the private sector right you
look at a guy like Tim Sloan this guy's
running Wells Fargo this is not an easy
job to get you got to be super smart
very educated very hardworking this guy
is running this major financial
institution then you have a 29 year old
bartender who lived with her parents
until two and a half years ago and she
is trying to grill him she's trying to
own him she wants a video that says AOC
owns the Wells Fargo Bank I it is not
possible and it's a real problem with
government because the kinds of people
who are super smart and super ambitious
and want to make a lot of money and are
really educated tend to not all the time
but tends to do what Tim Sloan did move
in that direction go into the private
sector go where their talents can be
rewarded and people who are subpar as a
matter of intelligence as a matter of
Education as a matter of work ethic tend
to go into the government not true all
the time some of the greatest men in
history have been statesmen Pericles was
very smart Winston Churchill Ronald
Reagan plenty plenty of very smart
educated know
hard-working people in government but
generally speaking that's the breakdown
and it just shows you where do you want
most of the country's resources to be
placed where do you want most of the
decision-making power in a country do
you want it to divide it up among free
people who are ambitious and smart
following their own self-interest
following the interest of their families
and their friends and their communities
the the far greater percentage of people
the overwhelming majority of people who
are like Tim Sloane or do you want it in
a bunch of dumb uneducated uncurious
lazy bureaucrats this is this video is
one of the great clips for small
government in the history of film now
speaking of small government
conservatism we will analyze why Mike
Lee and Joni Ernst's newpaper in to
leave policy is wrongheaded
but first let's make a little money
honey with ring rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or surprise visitor you'll get an alert
and be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone that is thanks
to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices so you know we
here at the daily wire love ring we all
have ring I give ring to my friends
senior producer Jonathan hey the other
day comes in he shows me he says you got
to see what happened at 3:00 in the
morning at 3:00 in the morning these two
whacked-out druggies ring his doorbell
he wakes up he looks at his phone goes
through his ring doorbell he says yeah
ello and these two people doped up out
of their mind say huh hey so where's the
I heard there's a drug shelter nearby
obviously these guys were just trying to
see if he was home they were gonna rob
the place the most incompetent burglars
in history but he was able to talk to
them wake up scare them off know that
they were there go downstairs turn the
lights on let him know that someone was
actually home I've heard a lot of
stories like this and I got to see it
with my own eyes as a listener you have
a special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to start building a ring of
security
your home just go to ring.com slash
Knowles kena wles ring.com
slash Knowles all right we have a new
conservative welfare program today
I put the word conservative in quotes
this is from Mike Lee one of the great
senators I'm a huge admirer of Mike Lee
but he's getting this one wrong it's
from Joni Ernst the bill is called the
cradle Act these acronym bill there's
just so the Krait the child rearing and
development leave empowerment Act
thank goodness these people went into
government and not into poetry our
literature would be even worse off than
it is the cradle act a well-meaning Act
to offer paid parental leave - everybody
here or Mike Lee and Joni Ernst
defending I think most people would look
at this is an opportunity that they
might not otherwise have an opportunity
to benefit from payments if they've been
making already for years why is the u.s.
so far behind the rest of the
industrialized world on this issue I
think that is a really great question
and that's why we have decided now is
the time to step up and really do
something about this we think it's time
to catch up with other countries first
of all this line of argument when is the
u.s. going to catch up with the rest of
the world this instantly tells you that
whatever is being discussed is extremely
wrongheaded this is what people say
about soccer this is what people say
about socialist health care this is
listen the rest of the world does a lot
of terrible things that they pretend are
progress and we don't do them and that's
a very good thing that we don't do them
because civilization survives just a
little bit longer the u.s. does not
trail the rest of the world in anything
we are the undisputed leader of the
world there isn't a second place there
it is not even close there is no
comparison
so this fiction that we are trailing the
rest you know we're trailing the rest of
the world in random killings on the
streets were trailing the rest of the
world it no there's no trailing we're
trailing the rest of the world in
destroying our government no we're not
sure things that yeah they're bad things
in America we are destroying our
government people do kill each other
of course yeah there are problems in
America but just say that America is
somehow far behind the rest of the world
and we just need to emulate France and
then everything will be great
give me a break that's ridiculous what
is the proposal the cradle' Act would
provide one or two or three months paid
parental leave that is borrowed from
Social Security so people who are less
likely to receive employer-sponsored
benefits are likely to get better
benefits from this program the payments
that you would get them from the
government require that you live in the
same house as your child for at least
half of the year to get the payments and
the cost is estimated at about nine
billion dollars per year although very
likely this is a low estimate other
people are putting that cost it may be
twice that just look at the criteria
here look on the good side on the good
side this does a really good thing which
is addressing a real problem which is
low birthrate the replacement rate for
births is 2.1 kids per couple the
current US birthrate is 1.7 kids per
couple our own population is declining
that's why we have to flood our country
with immigrants to maintain our quality
of life let's look at the provisions
here one two or three months paid leave
now the good side of this is that the
money comes out of Social Security so
it's money that you've already paid for
that hopefully you'll you know there it
won't cost the federal government very
much because you won't get it on the
back end this is obviously politically
ridiculous it's one of these things that
is economically sort of plausible and
politically not plausible nobody when
the when the first recipients of this
program start to retire nobody is going
to deprive them of their Social Security
it's just not going to happen they're
gonna raise Social Security payments
they're going to there are already are
different entitlements associated with
this those entitlements will grow
Democrats are already against that it's
jit that's just not gonna happen one two
or three months paid leave one two or
three months paid leave doesn't do very
much this is the other issue because it
doesn't actually address the birth rate
problem there are studies that show that
government programs such as this paid
parental leave can increase births
that's true
but these studies tend to show that over
much longer more robust paid parental
leave programs so in Germany for
instance you get over a year paid
parental leave and in Russia similar
thing much longer paid parental leave
program it will increase births but
we're not talking about over a year
we're not talking about twelve or
fourteen or sixteen months we're talking
about at most three months is anybody
really gonna say oh hey look it looks
like I'll get somewhere around six weeks
paid parental leave so let's start
having more kids Johnny yeah I'll get to
stay home with my kid for like eight
weeks and then I have to go bed though
that way we've bonded that way the cost
of child care doesn't matter that no of
course not no way there's no evidence
that that amount of time does anything
to birth wakes and and also by the way 1
to 3 months is nothing this is the other
issue I suppose the idea here is you
have a kid and then you want to bond
with your kid is there any evidence
that's staying home with your kid for a
month and then shoving them off to
daycare and you go back to work that
that solidifies the bond and okay
everything's good now or is there any
evidence that you take one month to bond
with your kid and then you shove them
off to daycare that that saves you a lot
of money
no the kid's gonna be in daycare until
he's like four or five one month out of
that is nothing one month out of what 48
60 months no that's not going to save
you a lot of money also Democrats are
already trying to make this a much wider
entitlement so now Democrats don't want
to just limit this to parents they want
to make it about sick relatives too they
want sick leave so kirsten gillibrand
who i guess is running for president no
I mean she's probably not gonna make it
to the first debate but she's now got
this bill the family and medical
insurance Leave Act family and medical
and this would give 12 weeks paid family
leave through the payroll tax so it's
not coming out of your Social Security
it's going to come through the payroll
tax and what's going to happen you're
going to get the downside of the demo
kratz doing what they've done for
decades which is demagogue the issue of
social security say that Republicans
want to throw a granny off a cliff they
want to rob you of your entitlement
you're gonna get that with really no
tangible benefit I'm highly skeptical
that this is going to increase birth
rates it's not going to alleviate
financial strain on middle class and
lower middle-class and working-class
families who have kids who need to go to
work and need to pay for child care what
does it accomplish it's a little
feel-good thing
because somebody in the president Trump
orbit decided that it was a good idea
for conservatives to embrace pointless
welfare programs and I think everybody's
just too timid to point out to those
people that that's a bad idea and a
leftist idea it's not even going to work
it's just a bad idea what the question
you have to ask is what is the purpose
of the law the purpose of the law is not
to give people more money like Hairston
Gillibrand seems to think the purpose of
the law is not to make it easier for
mothers to have it all it's not it's not
the purpose of it very explicitly should
be to increase the birth rate because we
have an unsustainably low birth rate
right now in a country can't survive if
you don't have babies the purpose of the
law is to encourage people to have
children will this law achieve that no
now how do you achieve that then I guess
you could go in the really socialist
direction and say we're gonna give you
one year two years maybe paid family
leave why not why stop at one year let's
go all the way to two years we will pay
women although in this day and age
you're gonna have to pay men to do it
too and actually in this day and age
because single mothers and gay couples
can adopt children because it basically
anybody can adopt children now you're
looking at a whole population say we'll
offer you two years paid leave if you
have a kid or adopt a kid that creates a
pretty weird incentive doesn't it and
and if you include adoption in this as
the bill does then that doesn't increase
the birth rate does it maybe it does
maybe it has some secondary effect on
abortions but that connection is very
doobie
I mean this is the trouble with big
government programs is you have all
these secondary questions that come up
all of these weird incentives that crop
up all of very often what's happened is
that the the program doesn't achieve
what it sets out to achieve and
sometimes it hurts the very goal that it
sets out to achieve well this is a big
mistake a very big mistake the way to
achieve a higher birthrate which is a
noble goal I'm glad conservatives are
serious about addressing it is to
radically change the culture that's the
reason why do we have a low birthrate
now well it's because it's expected that
both parents are working all the time
because people have gotten accustomed to
a very high quality of life people don't
want to give that up why is that the
culture is a bit decadent what is
required to have a lot of kids and to
have them quickly and start having them
young and that requires that something's
got to give and traditionally that means
that the mother has to take care of the
children not all the time sometimes the
father stays home and to take care of
the children either way it works you
might have to adjust to a lower income a
lower net disposable income a lower
family wealth you might need to
prioritize having children you cannot
have it all this bill doesn't let you
have it all it just taxes you in the
future or borrows money from China or
prints money or raises debt or whatever
you cannot have every single thing you
want in a finite world so you have to
change the culture from a culture of
selfishness pure professional ambition
we talked yesterday about how in the
educational system the reason the
college admissions scam happened is
because a democratic and egalitarian
society can not tolerate difference in
diversity everybody has to be exactly
the same that is the leveling impulse of
democratic egalitarian society so what
happened in the old days if you were a
young person you had a lot of paths
before you you could join the military
after high school you could go get a job
you should could become an entrepreneur
you could go to a four-year college you
could go to a two-year college you could
go to a trade school you could get an
apprenticeship all of these different
things now we are told everybody has to
go to a four-year college it's the same
thing in the profession
life we are told every single person has
to have a career it has to be a
professional career you can't just have
a job you've got to have a really good
yuppie professional career you've got to
go do to do to do you've got to start
working at 22
you can't stop working until you're 65
you've got to delay having kids you've
got to send your kids off to daycare you
can't you need double income you need
blob do to do that's the only way to
live but that isn't true and the the
effect of that one effect that we're
seeing that this bill is trying to
address is that we're not having babies
anymore because everybody's off working
at the widget Factory
okay good for some people not good for
other people broadly not good for the
culture that's how you change it you're
not going to change it by some
overweening radical social engineering
federal law you're not going to change
that by conservatives suddenly becoming
the party or the the political movement
of big federal government it's just not
going to do it it's a it's a noble
purpose but a bad law we've got to get
to one of the other great stories of the
day you remember Media Matters went
after Tucker Carlson they they found
clips from him 12 years ago 13 years ago
saying shocking things on a radio shock
jock shell turns out the Media Matters
guy the head of Media Matters for
America Andrew Caruso ney is a trans
folk we've got his blog entries from
almost exactly the same time as they got
Tucker Carlson's radio calls we will go
through exactly what he says but first
go to Daly wire.com why you get me you
get the under Clavin sure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh
show you can test questions in the
mailbag you can test questions backstage
backstage is coming up to today actually
we're doing backstage just later today
the mailbags can we have tomorrow get
your questions in all of this and the
leftist tears tumblr this is Virgo this
the Tim Sloan edition all of these
tumblers obviously we're financed with
the help of Wells Fargo now as well as
17 or 18 other banks these are really
good this is the only safe way to
consume those leftist tears make sure
you get this or you will drown
go to daily wear comm we'll be right
back with a lot more
tonight tune in to our next episode of
daily wire backstage March Madness
edition daily wire god-king Jeremy
boring Ben Shapiro Andrew clave and
Alicia Kraus and I will be smoking
stogies drinking whiskey and laughing at
this wild world of politics in pop
culture as always only daily wire
subscribers get to ask the questions so
make sure to subscribe today well that
was fast
what was it two days ago Media Matters
for America took a shot at Tucker
Carlson they've dug up these old tapes
from a shock jock radio show and it had
Tucker making offensive jokes on them
and they said see Tucker Carlson has to
lose his Fox show now so in the minute
that happened I tweeted out I said you
know it sure would be a shame people dug
up some dirt on the Media Matters people
gosh wouldn't that be a shame to give
them a taste of their own medicine not
two or three days later we got it we got
it came out today
Andrew Caruso nay the president of Media
Matters for America he apparently had a
blog 2005-2006 somewhere around there at
the same time Tucker was calling in to
that radio show on that blog he made
degrading references to [ __ ] Jewry
and Bangladeshis Andrew Carr use Sony
I'll just read it myself he took issue
with a gang of transvestites and he
specifically took issue with the the
transvestites being referred to as
attractive he said quote did you notice
the word attractive what the f is that
doing in there is the writer a [ __ ]
lover too or perhaps he's just trying to
justify how these [ __ ] tricked this
Bangladeshi in the first place look man
we don't need to know whether or not
they were attractive the effing guy was
Bangladeshi
and while we're out what the heck was he
doing with seventy three hundred dollars
worth of stuff the guy's Bangladeshi
okay that's just one who whatever the
context is I don't know you can hear the
words in in this case I guess the
context doesn't really matter because
he's using all of two
derogatory terms now he's obviously
writing a humorous blog post right this
is supposed to be humor Tucker Carlson
was obviously calling into a humorous
radio show what this guy said according
to the left according to the left in
2019 what this guy said he's a lot worse
than what Tucker Carlson said he's trans
phobic he's racist
he's classist he's checking off all the
intersectional boxes he said he goes on
about the transgender stuff he says
quote that the police should tell people
to quote stay away from [ __ ] bars stay
away from places where Eddie Murphy and
Robert Downey jr. have are visiting
don't effing kiss a transvestite don't
bring a group of transvestites back to
your room etc okay he's got a real focus
on transvestites now this is back like
five minutes ago when people could make
jokes about men dressing up as women
that was a topic of humour now this is a
very somber very serious thing you could
never what's funny about that huh what's
funny about a man putting on lipstick in
dressing up like a woman
what's entertaining about that never
mind that drag bars have existed for all
of human history and they are all about
entertaining people and putting on a
show no no you can't laugh you have to
date SuperDuper serious you can't laugh
so Andrew Korea's Sony breaks the rules
he doesn't just talk about transvestites
though he writes about Japanese female
basketball players and he says that they
should stop complaining about sexual
abuse he says lighten up Japs
it's his line he extolled the virtues of
Senator Robert Byrd famously of the KKK
he also said thanks to my adorable
boyfriend come on
despite his Jewry you know he's adorable
you know cuz Jews are not cute or
attractive but despite that his
boyfriend is adorable that's according
to the blog posts he also said his
boyfriend lean conservative quote as a
consequence of his possession of several
bags of Jewish gold if you see the Jews
have all of this money and they're
greedy in they control the whole world
and they sell out for money that's
according to the head of Media Matters
for America
no but Michael he was making a joke yeah
I know right Tucker was making a joke
I'm all for jokes but this guy this hack
and Ricardo Soni is currently trying to
get Tucker Carlson fired for making less
offensive jokes that he did at the exact
same time that they both made them huh
well I guess if Tucker's gonna lose his
job I guess Ames worker USANA has to - I
don't think he should though I mean he
should just as a matter of fairness but
nobody should lose their job and I
actually first of all these these are
not gonna take him down because the left
doesn't actually care they don't
actually care about people confused
about their gender they don't actually
care about any racial minority they
don't care about women they don't care
about that they care about attacking the
right
they care about taking down Big Daddy in
the patriarchy so the left will not take
him down over this this probably won't
even be played on CNN but I think it
benefits us for him to be in his job I
think it's actually better to keep him
there so that we can point to him as an
example of hypocrisy I think this really
wounds Media Matters thing a really
wounds the credibility of media matters
because now whenever they point to
something that anybody says they're
gonna find something I said on some show
and they'll say see Michael needs to
lose his job
we'll just point to Andrew Carr you so
nay so you know this guy told Japanese
women to stop complaining about sexual
assault this guy said horrible things
about transgender people and this guy
made offensive comments about
Bangladeshis among other comments on his
blog and then they'll say well it just
it's kind of like the Liz Warren thing I
want Liz Warren to stay in the Senate
for as long as possible because she's a
joke
she has no credibility whatsoever she's
so professionally and politically
wounded it's better to have her there
rather than to have someone who still
has some credibility so hope he stays
there best of luck - Andrew Carr you so
named now it's kind of interesting too
because cargo Sonia says he was dating
this conservative guy I don't know if
they're still dating or if the guy is
still conserved
or whatever but this does remind me of
something which is that I've noticed
that very Provident left-wingers move
over to the right they become right-wing
activists major right-wing voices that
that is not true of right-wingers that
is generally not true of conservative
some you know little political
consultants get their 15 minutes of fame
by advising they used to advise liberal
Republicans now they advise liberal
Democrats or something and then Steve
Schmidt is an example of this say Oh see
look he went from right to left but of
the actual leftists of the actual
conservatives the real the true
believers who have a coherent political
philosophy or ideology it always seems
to move from left to right and we're
seeing this with the co-founder of
Greenpeace Greenpeace the major
environmentalist group he has come out
and said that the green New Deal could
end civilization completely you're one
of the founders of the most famous
environmental organization in the world
and you think the green New Deal sounds
terrifying
tell us why well because it would be
basically the end of a civilization if
85% of the world's and also 85 percent
of the US is energy in the form of coal
oil and natural gas were phased out over
the next few years like 10 years we do
not have anything to replace them with
yes if we went into a crash course of
building nuclear reactors we could
replace them for producing electricity
but that isn't going to happen because
the greens are against nuclear and
they're even against hydroelectric dams
which at least is renewable but they
don't support that either so basically
they are opposed to approximately 98.5
percent of all the electricity that we
are using and a nearly a hundred percent
of all the vehicle and transportation
and ships and planes energy that we are
using Wow so he says the end of
civilization we knew that I mean that is
what the green new deal calls for it
calls for spending ninety three trillion
dollars which you don't have you just
first of all tax anybody who creates any
economic growth and
job growth whatsoever you tax them into
oblivion then you just print money so
you destroyed the economy and you
destroy America's economic standing in
the world and then you outlaw virtually
all of American energy then you knock
down every single building in the
country obviously this would be the end
of civilization it's not just that he
says this but listen the way he's
talking about this he's citing very
specific facts examples some statistics
he's speaking with great detail and
great precision
compare that to aoc who is now the
leading environmentalist voice on the
left and she says it doesn't matter if
you're factually correct doesn't matter
that that's the difference and this guy
was a left winger he's the co-founder of
Greenpeace but he has moved from the
left to what would be called the right
on this issue and it's not just him
Norma McCorvey became one of the biggest
pro-life advocates in the country but
you probably don't know the name Norma
McCorvey because what she is most
famously known as is Jane Roe of Roe vs.
Wade this was the woman who almost
single-handedly got the Supreme Court to
create a fictional constitutional right
to abortion huge millions and millions
and millions of babies killed because of
her activism and she switched sides the
more she learned the more she grew in
wisdom she understood that this was a
horrible and grave injustice she became
a major pro-life advocate same thing
with dr. Bernard Nathanson dr. Bernard
Nathanson was one of the founders of
morale they've changed their name like
seven times but they've never changed
the acronym this is the major abortion
rights organization since the beginning
of the abortion movement in the 1960s
and 70s
this guy has come out he's become a
major pro-life advocate this guy
performed abortions I think and he came
out and he said look the statistics we
used were made up what we were doing was
barbaric it's wrong we shouldn't do it
it's terrible moved on over and now you
have Patrick Moore from Greenpeace the
major in
mentalist organization he comes out he
says no we were just wrong this is just
wrong why is this why do people move on
over it's because people over time grow
in wisdom generally that's the idea the
left has this opposite idea which is
that out of the mouths of babes come the
most beautiful truths in the world and
this people get older and they live in
the world they become corrupted and evil
and awful and so you should people who
are ignorant or actually wiser I mean
that's the idea that's how a OC becomes
the leading voice on the left because
youth immaturity ignorance is considered
a positive good this is considered
wisdom for a for an inverted political
ideology such as leftism there's that
old line if you're not a liberal when
you're 17 you have no heart if you're
not a conservative when you're 40 you
have no brain which is half true and
this reminds me of that I mean there is
a a natural evolution here and it's what
people will point to is all these a
little little pill Jennifer Rubin she's
a blogger and then she said she was
conservative and now she's leftist okay
what what right liberal Republicans
sometimes move to the left this is true
of other political pundits and
commentators but if the real guys the
real people in the arena the real people
doing something a major activists major
voices it doesn't ever seem to move that
way all right we've got a lot more to
get to but unfortunately we're out of
time that's our show we'll get tomorrow
to why the death penalty is a good thing
and why Nancy Pelosi is not going to
impeach the president get your mailbag
questions in I'll see you later for
backstage in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19